[Music]
all right welcome back to the special
edition of Hannity Trump versus the
resistance now is the molar witch-hunt
continues there's still no evidence of
any Trump Russia collusion so ask
yourself why was the Michael Cohen
filing done on the eve of this
high-stakes g20 summit this is not the
first time this has happened remember
the Paul Manafort indictment George
papadopolis guilty plea both announced
just days before the president left for
a historic 12 day trip to Asia and White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders she
said today that the probe may be hurting
the US ties with Moscow all suggesting
that the special counsel may be trying
to derail the Trump presidency in more
ways than one joining us now with
reaction author of the bestseller
Trump's America the truth about our
nation's great comeback Fox News
contributor and former Speaker of the
House Newt Gingrich you know one of the
things you talked about the success of
Trump in your book but then you also
have the warnings warnings warnings what
the president needs to be aware of
obviously I stand on my original premise
Muller is out for blood
Muller picked this team of Democratic
donors even Clinton's old lawyer at the
foundation Andrew Weissman and company
for a reason he is gold he wants to hurt
the president as badly as he can that's
why he's offering all these
get-out-of-jail-free cards if you just
say whatever we want you to say okay I
think we ought to quit talking about the
Muller investigation and start talking
about the Muller Trump destruction
project because it's very clear that
Muller and his left-wing lawyers are
methodically doing everything they can
to destroy the president and in effect
to create a non Justice Department
because this is not justice a non
Justice Department coup d'etat in which
they undo the votes of the American
people and they pile enough junk and
then this stuff that's what all the
stuff is they pile enough junk around
that they just gradually overwhelm
President Trump and I think if you start
and you look at everything they've been
doing and you said you know from day
this was never about Russian collusion
this was never about finding the truth
this was about a methodical effort to
destroy President Trump by any means
necessary
and you look at some of the things that
are getting indictments on I mean again
somebody goes and lies to the Congress
that's stupid
they deserve to be indicted I'm not in
any way defending Cohen but they were
lying about stuff that wasn't a crime
it's the point that Andy McCarthy keeps
making as a former Justice Department
lawyer that none of the underlying
patterns were crimes people are allowed
to be in business people are allowed to
do deals people allowed to do lots of
stuff and yet what you get of course is
the headline in the elite media that
somehow this is another terrible blow to
Trump what it really is is further proof
that Muller's interest is in destroying
the Trump presidency and your point is
exactly right
they had no reason to release this as
the president goes to an important
meeting in Argentina with 19 other world
leaders I mean this is sort of like
undermining America for partisan reasons
you've been in the minority in Congress
and you were the speaker in Congress a
lot easier to be the speaker I'm just
guessing although you take a lot more
incoming let's be honest you took all
you took your fair share so we don't
have an agenda the Democrats in the
house all they're saying endless endless
endless investigation Nancy Pelosi's
first agenda item she announced earlier
today Oh
released Donald Trump's taxes now that's
not going anywhere in the Senate a good
thing the president went out to campaign
very hard to keep the Senate because
that's going to help him but it's still
the intention what I don't see an agenda
to serve the American people
well I remember Sean this is what people
have to understand there's a 1923 law
which allows the chair of the Ways and
Means Committee to request the tax
returns of any American so I can imagine
a circumstance with a new chairman at
the Liberal Democrat will exercise his
legal right the Internal Revenue Service
will turn over the Trump tax returns
which are supposedly
secret and the release of which would be
a felony and then by some magic method
that all of us will be shocked at
they'll turn out on page one of the New
York Times so I would not mean these
people are playing for blood this is
more like the terror and the French
Revolution than it is like traditional
American politics they will do anything
break any rules and I think break any
law if it will enable them to get Donald
Trump let's go to the border it was
interesting during the campaign oh that
they're just they're just trying to gin
up racial tensions this isn't real
they're a thousand miles away well
they're not a thousand miles away
anymore and Border Patrol agents pelted
with rocks bottles projectiles and but
using the same tactics that Obama used
interestingly nobody cared then tear gas
to disperse crowds that were trying to
break down the wall and and enter the
country and charge into the country
illegally pretty severe crisis in Mexico
then you have six hundred criminals
identified by the DHS and Mexican
officials that have infiltrated the
caravan how do you put where do we go
from here how do you stop that from
happening
should ask their Democratic congressman
or senator are you really comfortable
with six hundred identified criminals
coming into the United States in just
one particular wave the remember if they
get to come in this time the number of
people will be coming north in the next
six months will be amazing because
people are down there watching to see
what happens and I think it's it's
astonishing to me that Senator Schumer
speaker Pelosi nobody's held accountable
when you get a report from the
Department of Homeland Security that in
this particular group there are six
hundred people who are convicted
criminals now I suspect the average
American if that was presented to them
which it won't be by the elite news
won't be on the New York Times page one
but that's that's an astonishing piece
of data so I think that the president
simply has to come back home keep
driving the points he's the one person
who can break through the news blackout
and get the truth emeriti chiclet
bad idea to either a use the
reconciliation process to get full
funding of the wall over the president
to say I'll just shut down the
government and just wait well I think
the president's already indicated what
he may do is shut the border and and see
how much how rapidly that causes a real
pain level I mean the number of American
businesses will be knocking on doors in
Congress within two days will be amazing
all right mr. speaker thanks for being
with us